Hollywood is full of rumors and one of
the wildest dates back to the early 90s
when Tupac Shakur and Janet Jackson were
filming the romantic drama poetic
justice as the rumor goes Jackson
refused to kiss her co-star unless he
agreed to get an AIDS test the keep you
head up rapper reportedly refused
telling the source that he took the
request as a quote insult throughout the
years both stars have touched on the
subject with Shakur saying at times that
it was absolutely true however in a 2019
Interview With The Daily Beast late
director John Singleton explained the
whole thing was supposed to be funny
although Tupac might have missed a joke
he said we were on the set joking with
Janet there and the whole cast and I was
like I don't know if I want you kissing
my actresses I don't know where your
lips have been and it became a joke and
then a joke turned into some publicity
and Tupac was the only one that was left
out of the circle while Singleton later
claimed Tupac was in on the joke the
rumor still lingers with the truth maybe
somewhere in the middle